mademoiselle s'il vous plaît vous êtes
en retard ça va arriver avec sa monture
tard pourquoi vous vous acharnez sur moi
comme ça là voilà le complexe de
persécution qui pourrait être typique
s'y pique nique de quoi exactement fait
sur un assist de 10 à les balles n'ont
pas complètement pété les plombs
je suis obligé de le faire passer en
conseil de discipline c'est pas
politiquement correct c'est ça qu'il
faut bien fermer la gueule aux recteurs
tu m'as préservant autant concours
d'éloquence et mais moi je veux rien du
tout vous on pousse ces luttes entre les
modes nella salah hamouri rien s'est
bien passé 3 le racisme a dit marc
comment me rappelle quand allez vous
vous débarrasser de votre foutrement
deux banlieusardes informe je vous aime
pas mais vous croyez quoi qu'on n'ait
pas jugé sur son apparence la manière
dont tout se présente au monde n'a pas
d'importance
l'éloquence la rhétorique c'est
précisément ça que je vous apporte à
avoir raison la vérité on s'en fout et
bien si ces pratiques amis histoire toi
peux-tu devient la star de la fac et lui
la droite continue est un gros raciste
je comprends pas là tesson amende
honorable
oui c'est ça fais toi mais tu t'es pas
servi plus toi aussi
du coup je n'étais pas à ma place voilà
mais ce que j'ai rencontré abandonne pas
comme ça soyez fiers de ce que vous êtes
je veux vous entendre je veux que votre
voix résonne
jure de dire la vérité même si je mens
comme je respire je sais qu'un jour
s'attachera à mon nom le souvenir de
quelque chose de formidable
mettez-vous ce stylo dans la bouche
comme ça et articulés comme ça va c'est
halal là c'est une provocation
[Musique]